I fully respect the decision that the
police have reached I paid the fpn
straight away and I'm extremely and
sincerely sorry for the hurt and the
anger that this has caused so many
people and with regard to I've always
acted I believe in good faith with
regard to what I've said to Parliament
and did you consider resigning at any
points yeah I'm focused on getting on
with the job I've got to do it's a it's
a difficult time for many people across
the world as we're discussing here in
Washington people are grappling with
globally Rising prices what I'm doing is
working tirelessly day and night to do
what I can to support the British people
and the economy through these times
that's why a few weeks ago we announced
nine billion pounds of support to help
with Energy prices raise the national
living ways cutting taxes for 30 million
people 330 pounds to someone in work
those are the kinds of things that I'm
focused on doing and that's what I think
people would expect me to do come back
to that in a moment just on the issue of
the green card it does seem like a
significant anomaly that an MP a
minister a chance of the exchequer would
have the rights that's only normally
granted to someone seeking permanent
residency in this country uh what was
that an oversight or do you intend to
sort of come back to America
no I I've had a green card because I as
a legacy of my time living and working
in America nothing more than that I
always believe I've acted on the advice
of officials with regard to my
disclosures but to provide complete
reassurance and Clarity for everyone
I've asked the prime minister's
independent advisor to review all my
disclosures to provide that Clarity and
reassurance for people and indeed on my
my first trip last year to the us as
Chancellor I discussed with the US
authorities the appropriate course of
action and at that point uh returned my
green card okay on the issue of your
family finances I know you'll say that
this is the substance of inquiry from
Lord guide will have to wait but can you
in general answer the question as to
whether your household finances did
benefit or could benefit from the
non-domocell stages of your wife I think
my my wife has made her own statement
about these matters she's always
followed all the rules paid all the tax
in the UK that is due and pay tax
internationally on her International
Investments but she reckon recognizes
this goes beyond just following those
rules so she's decided to pay both UK
and foreign taxes on her foreign
investments and I fully support her
decision to do so